local gun clubs are a German tradition
that goes back centuries many towns and
villages have them
most of the members of the shooting
fraternity in Hakam Hawk in the
Rhineland are Catholics even its slogan
refers to religion faith morality
homeland it says of the club stipulates
that members have to be of the Christian
faith and accept and conform to
fundamental Christian values and
principles that means the Muslim or
atheist wouldn't have a chance
formerly that's not possible that's
right because gun clubs and shooting
fraternities are rooted in tradition and
target shooting is a skill the European
Union has petitioned to have the
organization's listed as intangible
heritage in UNESCO World Cultural
Heritage Program but UNESCO sent the
application back citing clauses in some
clubs charters that exclude religious
diversity anthropologists say these are
no longer appropriate today cut it's
your traditions on things like putting
granny's coffee pot in the glass cabinet
only to never touch or move it
traditions are living and must be
actively experienced within the context
of society Liv Verdun was UNESCO s
disagreement with the shooting clubs was
triggered by a case from zonin in
Westphalia
a Turkish German mitat kaduk was named
king of the marksman's festival in the
summer of 2014 but because he was a
Muslim his club was threatened with
expulsion from the fraternity's national
organization the conflict has escalated
to the point where neither getting more
his shooting fraternity nor UNESCO want
to give an interview on the issue the
Gurdit case has tarnished the image of
the shooting clubs more and more say
they plan to become more diverse and
open in future the marksmen in bush -
near Bonn amended their charter a few
years ago they're no longer a fraternity
now they call themselves a sports
shooting club atheists and Muslims can
join religion is no longer important but
that's not the case with the natural
association I'll be perfectly honest
with you these people have a screw loose
that's all there is to it
anyone who says things like that is
really strange the debate about
traditional and modern clubs has got the
people in Bush - all wound up they don't
want any club in their village to
exclude Muslims
the skipper's there feel immense there
are plenty of people who think that's
bad and say we don't want to have
anything to do with him one well the
next apartment and at the fraternity in
hackin Wharf in the Rhineland they're
also coming round to the idea that
Muslim neighbors should be able to join
the club to do plays cards and dice with
us why shouldn't he be able to join the
club and wear the uniform we're talking
about people and not religions or
personal attitudes now the National
Association wants to reconsider its
position as well